1,700 sheep on their way to their winter
pasture no easy job for the sheepdogs
but they're lying in the grass paying no
attention to their master says they're
too tired from driving away wolves at
night the flocks spent the summer in the
mountains now as every year when tens of
thousands of sheep are on the move
the Wolves come timo Popish Valley from
the knackers conservation organization
wants to set up corridors in which their
attacks are tolerated the Shepherd's
call him the wolf man they complain that
their flocks have less room with more
and more roads and fences and can't
believe they should now show
consideration for wolves keeping their
dogs back and not shooting them I don't
know what they think of me I hope they
understand that our organization is
trying to support them but sometimes
when we talk about predators and their
being part of George's ecosystem there
are differences of opinion there are
many endangered species in Georgia wild
cats golden jackals Eurasian Lynx
light-colored Syrian brown bears and
Eurasian wolves
the flocks move across the countryside
twice a year in spring and in autumn
it's been like that for centuries the
sheep spend the winter in the southeast
of the country in Vashon Avani National
Park
Timo puppyish Veliz main area of
operations this place is very important
to me
I love Bosch Levani especially because
of its spectacular views and the
wildlife here makes the park unique it's
the largest and best protected area in
southeastern Georgia though pro Nicholas
but there are still poachers many bears
used to live in these ravines now just
20 remain sometimes they come up and
kill a sheep if that happens the sheep
farmer loses about 100 euros now kress
can't compensate him for his loss but
killing a bear would be an irretrievable
loss for George's ecosystem